gang Fest features over 90 different
comedians wow who would you say is the
most underrated comic Here Blake Hammond
from Cincinnati Blake Hammond so funny
dude he looks kind of like a little
armadillo of a man but his jokes are
rock solid and uh he's opening for like
he opened for Canan he opened for Norman
and Cincinnati yeah Blake's the most
underrated guy here for sure okay you've
never heard of him no and your whole job
is aggregating comedy content who is the
most underrated comedian at skankfest
who would that be oh my God what a
question um the most underrated at
skankfest I don't know dude I love
Brendan zagalo so much he's a I his
podcast is breaking up but like a
phoenix he's going to Rise From the
Ashes and I'm encouraging to focus on
comedic rap he's so good at freestyling
okay and who would the most overrated C
no I'm just kid